hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in letter 74
Seneca is providing us readers with some
helpful insights about virtue and why
from stomache perspective virtue is
really the only good even though we talk
about many other things as being Goods
and it's worth reminding herself about
something that he's taking for granted
as he's making all of his arguments and
exportations in this and that is when we
view something as good because of the
way we we are we're naturally drawn to
desire it to try to obtain it to protect
it when we have it and when we see
something correlative ly as bad or as
evil we're going to try to avoid it and
so the question is what is the genuine
good because we we want to orient
ourselves properly if we don't there's
going to be some bad consequences for us
and so he he talks about this now before
we go into this we want to clarify
terminology a little bit so in this
translation we we have that the only
genuine good is honorable conduct right
but it could also be translated as just
the honorable and the too
in terms that are being used there are
good bonum this classification right
things that are good in whatever sense
we're going to talk about and then the
Stoics say the only thing that really is
genuinely good the only thing that
deserves the name of good is what in
Latin they call the whole nest um the
word that we get honest from and you
know over the years that has come to
take on a sort of connotation of just
being about truth but it really has to
do with all of our conduct so an honest
person is somebody who behaves the way
that they ought to sort of across the
board for the Stoics so what they're
asserting here is that the only thing
that really is good is whatever counts
as ho nest them whatever is honorable
and that is going to turn out to be the
virtues and virtuous actions and also
virtuous people so what happens if you
don't view things this way he says that
he who regards other things as good is
dominated by fortune and subject to
another's whim he limits goodness to
what his honorable is happy within
himself now this term fortune is going
to come up over and over again here and
again a little bit of clarification is
probably necessary when the ancients are
talking about fortune they don't just
mean the individual fortune that you
wind up with we typically think of a
fortune as riches right but it could be
all sorts of other things they talked
about fortune or Fortuna in Latin as
being sort of it could be a you know a
goddess or it could be the just this
cosmic process that a lots different
things to different people and does so
in a kind of random way so if we're
thinking about money you know some
people get money some people don't get
money other people get good health and
other people get bad health and you can
ask yourself well why did I get cancer
dumb luck you know or it could be the
fact that you smoke four packs a day
they might have a little bit to do with
it or you might have been the poorer
person who lived upstairs from the
chimney smoke
person who's you know going through four
packs a day and yet secondhand smoke all
of these things that are kind of random
are fortunate so if we think about what
things we typically call goods are
subject to fortune and which ones aren't
we see here that we're laying ourselves
into some real problems and I'll just
give you a few examples that he brings
up one person is grieved when his
children died understandably right I
think all of us can relate to that in
some way worried when they're sick
another is sad when they're a base
character and tinged with notoriety this
fellow is racked with love for another's
wife this one with love for his own now
notice that example so this is this poor
miserable guy over here is desiring
somebody else's wife and so he's got a
lot of you know troubles trying to
seduce her and not get you know caught
by the jealous husband and you know
turned into a sitcom or something like
that but this guy over here
just happens to feel that same level of
desire for his own wife I mean she might
not return his affections or you know
maybe there's there's you know things
that impede and impinge they're stuck
across the ocean from each other
whatever it is his desire is going to be
unsatisfied and because of that he's
going to be unhappy he says of all the
suffering crowds of humankind the
greatest of those who are troubled by
the thought of death like troops passing
through enemy territory they must be
looking around all the time unless this
fear is driven from the breasts we live
with quaking hearts so you know so long
as we're viewing all sorts of other
things as goods which the stoical say
are not genuine goods we're actually
going to be unhappy we're going to be
subject to fortune because we're waiting
for things to come to us we're gonna be
miserable and he's got this this great
metaphor here he says set before
yourself the following image fortune is
putting on a festival elected office
wealth popularity that those are the
things that fortune is distributing
through the crowd some of this largesse
is torn to bits by many grasping hands
some shared out and faithless bargains
some
carried off to the detriment of those
who get it some of that falls to the
inattentive some is knocked away by
those trying to eagerly to snatch it
even when luck attends the catching none
of it brings anyone a joy that lasts
even till tomorrow
the intelligent person what are they
gonna do they're gonna look at this
little bit what I'm getting out of here
right they know that small favors may
come at a high price he says no one is
grappling with him as he's leaving north
no one throws a punch as he's headed for
the door everybody's scuffling around
all the loot the same thing he says
happens with the gifts that fortune
showers upon us poor things were all in
a fever and a fret we wish we had many
hands isn't that a wonderful before but
two hands are not enough to snatch it
all the great stuff that's coming our
way and push off the other people so
they don't get get their grubby hands on
it that's not to be happy I mean unless
you really just love competing with
people then that I suppose could make
you happy in a sense so he says when
these gifts come we think they're too
slow and coming they come to so few
they'll all expect them we want to be
where they're falling we rejoice if we
catch a few where others have been
disappointed and so he says you know the
person who's determined to be happy
can't take that point of view they need
to make up their mind instead that the
only thing that's really genuinely good
for us is virtue is honorable conduct so
it's a narrowing of scope of what
actually counts as the good
he gives us a number of arguments
worried what you could call
considerations for why we should accept
this point of view that he's putting
forth that of the Stoics so the first
one has to do with thinking ill of
Providence and this may not be very
convincing to a modern audience he says
if he imagines that there's any other
good he thinks ill of Providence since
many uncomfortable things happen to just
men and whatever gifts we do receive our
small and brief duration compared to the
age of the universe it is in consequence
that of the
a complaint that we are such thankless
interpreters of the divine we complain
our blessings are not ours forever and
you know so all of that if we really
took the right point of view and we do
think that there is some sort of
providential ordering of things and we
see the fact that you know a lot of just
people or good people don't get good
outcomes and a lot of you know by
opposition a lot of bad people get good
things or things at least we're calling
good maybe we shouldn't call those
things good
maybe we shouldn't view money or income
or notoriety or celebrity as genuine
goods I mean if any old schmuck can get
them just because they're there you know
happening to be worked out in that way
by whatever Providence is and fortune
working with Providence in some unknown
way then we probably shouldn't view them
as Goods if we're going to view them as
good then Providence sucks
Providence is terribly arranged you know
whether it's God or something else
divine mind it's not doing a good job so
if we want to say that it is doing a
good job
we'd better restrict the goods that
we're calling good again probably not
that convincing to too many modern
interpreters here's another more
powerful position virtue lacks nothing
he says at a couple different points
says do you ask why virtue lacks nothing
virtue rejoices in present Goods has no
longing for what is absent finds nothing
meager that will suffice abandon this
attitude loyalty is lost integrity is
lost in it to preserve these values you
have to endure many things that are
regarded as bad go on is courage
gone as greatness of spirit right
gratitude is lost and readiness so
virtue virtue is satisfied with what's
there a little bit later on he says
virtue leaves no space empty it occupies
the entire mind virtue by itself is
enough for it has within it the strength
and source of good things so
this is a way of saying if you actually
do have virtue not just you know the
semblance of virtue not just saying that
virtue is a good thing if you actually
commit yourself to it and you develop
virtue within you
stoic virtues of wisdom for you know
fortitude or courage temperance or
moderation and justice you will already
have your reward because virtue is the
good so that's an argument that they
give another one that's really
interesting is this consideration of the
human being as kind of poise between the
divine and the animal and what Seneca
has to say here is really quite clever
so we've got to you know let's say two
different kinds of potential goods he's
going to say one of these is not
actually good we've got things that we
recognize as intrinsically good like
virtues right and virtuous behavior the
the ho nessam the Honorable and then
we've got all these other things that
human beings consider good like you know
let's be really crude with this partying
you know eating lots of good food
getting laid you know having a good time
all that sort of stuff here's where the
argument goes and it's really quite
interesting so the gods are above or the
divine or whatever it is and animals are
below now human beings it can enjoy both
of these sorts of things the virtues and
all these other creature comforts let's
call them right who else enjoys creature
comforts it's not the gods they don't
have anything of that right it's animals
and who enjoys the intrinsically good
virtue it's the gods the animals have
nothing of that now here's our Senecas
going with us are you gonna say that the
gods are in some respect lacking
compared to human beings because human
beings can savor the you know the taste
of a wonderful pizza the gods don't care
about that sort of stuff so is is the
position of the God somehow worse off
then the head of the humans I mean if
these things are goods that's what
you're saying or if we go the other way
and we want to say these things
our goods animals seem to be enjoying
them way more than we do he he says this
animals partake of food more eagerly are
less exhausted by sexual intercourse
have greater and more consistent
strength therefore they must be happier
than human beings if we want to think
about distinctively human happiness
maybe we need to locate it in virtue not
in all these creature comforts right
that's a really interesting argument
that he's giving they're almost
immediately after that he makes a really
helpful clarification well you know if
people call these things Goods what's
going on here why why would they call
something good that's not actually good
and here he the translation is is that
these are actually not goods as such
these are comfort she says the goods
that reason gives are real they're solid
and eternal they cannot fail that cannot
decrease or be diminished those others
are the goods of opinion goods of
opinion they're not real goods they're
what in other places we call apparent
goods and they share their name with
real goods but the distinctive property
of the good is not in them for this
reason he says let them be termed
comforts or to use our schools
terminology preferred things and
comforts is translating Komoda things
that are you know useful for us things
that are satisfying to our bodies things
that may be gratifying to our minds as
well but they're not the genuine good
they don't have the the good within them
as such they're only you might say good
for something so you know like eating
tasty food is good for the tongue and
perhaps good for the the spirit in a
certain way it cheers you up a little
bit we can talk about comfort food if we
just stick with food right all sorts of
great examples we've got the the rich
food of a banquet we have the you know
food that's that's better for our body
we have the comfort food that we turn to
when we're feeling blue like the person
and the the movie eating from a gallon
of ice cream in front of the
refrigerator
Vall yeah we could multiply examples of
this right the Stoics call those things
preferred indifference not preferred
Goods preferred indifference and they
say that they have some value to them
but it's not the kind of value that is
that of the good as such it's not it's
not anything that yes there's virtue but
they can be used virtuously we can use
these things rightly it doesn't mean
that we have to suddenly become ascetics
and say I will have nothing to do with
anything that's not virtue itself no we
can we can use these things properly
using them properly means recognizing
that they are fleeting that we may not
be able to hold on to them forever and
that our happiness does not lie in them
here's where we get to a really
interesting discussion and here's where
he says a lot of people talk to the to
the Stoics and they say this is a real
problem for you says this armament will
not make you safe from fortune and
invulnerable for among goods your school
includes devoted children good customs
in one's homeland and good parents when
those are endangered you cannot look on
with anxiety you will be disturbed by an
attack on your homeland the death of
your children or the enslavement of your
parents sounds like a pretty good point
doesn't it the Stoics do in fact say
well yes the the core of good is is
virtue but you know these other things
are good by a kind of extension doesn't
that now make them vulnerable to the
world in a way that seems to go against
stoic philosophy and he says in my reply
I'm going to set down the points that we
make on behalf of our school than a
further response I think needs to be
made so here's the stoic response the
situation is different with those things
whose loss means they're replaced by
some discomfort the example when health
is ruined it turns into its opposite ill
health
when keen eyesight is extinguished we
are afflicted afflicted with blindness
when the tendons of the knee are cut we
not only lose the ability to run quickly
but become lame as well but with the
objects I mentioned just
parents children and homeland there is
no such risk if I've lost a good friend
I need not suffer disloyalty in his
place if my good children have died and
neglectful ones do not succeed them that
may not be that great of an argument
when you hear it another is that he says
in these cases it's not the friends or
the children that are lost but only
their bodies isn't that an interesting
thing for a stoic who's a materialist to
say he says well if one's friends have
perished and children have proven worth
have also perished we have something to
fill the void what is this thing that
fills the void the same thing that made
them good virtue now that's a really
interesting consideration because virtue
seems to be something very abstract how
does that satisfy your sense of loss of
a human being
presumably the virtue must be kind of
individuated the virtue of my daughter
if I'm Cicero thinking about Tullio
right the virtue of this good friend if
I've lost a good friend so there there's
an interesting consideration and then he
goes on and he says what are you saying
how could a person not be happier when
surrounded by a crowd of friends and
children and here Seneca says let's
think about a circle right if it's a big
circle or a little circle it's still a
circle it still has the same shape it's
still what it is and he goes on and says
sometimes virtue expands its scope it
rules kingdoms cities provinces looks
after friendships performs various
responsibilities among neighbors and
children other times it's enclosed
within a tight boundary of poverty exile
or bereavement but it's not made smaller
when brought down to earth from a
loftier pinnacle from the estate of
Kings to that of the private citizen to
the limitations of a single household or
even a corner it's equally great even if
it withdraws into itself closed off on
every side and then he says okay so
those are the arguments
make here's my own account the wise
person is not afflicted by the loss of
children or friends because he endures
their death in the same spirit as he
awaits his own he does not fear the one
any more than he grieves over the other
for virtue is made of consistency all
its actions harmonize and agree with
each other and this is lost when the
mind is brought down by grief so that
that's Senecas own take on this so what
is he providing us with here in these
these arguments and considerations the
key to human happiness from the stoic
perspective we have to view virtues as
the only good and stick with that idea
then we have to act and organize one's
life accordingly it doesn't do any good
to give lip service to well virtue is
the only good but I'm gonna behave in a
way inconsistent with that and we have
to do so in a world that is you know
presumably governed by Providence but
subject to fortune with a mind inside of
a body and there's one consideration
that he brings up here he says somebody
could object doesn't the wise person
experience something similar to emotion
when his color change his expression to
show signs of alarm his limbs grow cold
all those sorts of things and Seneca
says yes he will but he will remain
unchanged in his conviction that not one
of the objects mentioned is bad or that
such that a sound mind should quail at
it everything that's to be done he'll do
promptly and boldly so we you know we
have bodies and and they're gonna act in
certain ways but we don't have to go
along with that we can still behave
virtuously and if we do so we will in
fact be happy according to the stoic
conception of happiness
you